Paul is here winter is coming there's
always the coolest eye of the season I'm
here with Jim Moore and fashion editor
John teats and we're gonna look at the
coolest highs for right now Jim you got
a bunch behind you what is going on back
there bring racket eyes everywhere I go
I think if we were standing here a year
or two ago most of these times would be
silk right believe it or not every one
of these times are wool these are not
the old wooly ties you remember of the
past it's not a fox hunting tie this is
not like you know you're in Scotland
this is the business - I know it's
sending emails what we do now we got it
down to these five because they kind of
serve a different purpose in a guy's
wardrobe this is that your wool tie
arsenal right yeah the first one is a
mini check and we love how dressy this
is next to that we have a houndstooth
this was on the cover of the September
issue GQ maybe smoking a pickle I'll get
a pickle in a habit of having a mug of
coffee
that's from Tommy Hilfiger that's an
awesome time this is from a relatively
new tie designers and as Alexander mulch
and this is what I'd call a blanket plan
and it's the thing I love about is yes
it's a big plaid but there's a real
subtlety to it because it this pale gray
I have a question about a tie like this
could you wear it with a patterned suit
you could but you would want this shirt
to be solid right sir balance and
everything else exactly right this next
one is called a foulard and this is
printed on wool this is a real old time
fabric and I'm telling you this tie will
looks so good with anything from a great
suit for a navy suit to a pinstripe to
tweed jacket this is a wool rep tie and
I have to say that this is one of the
most unusual because you always see rep
ties itself well we see them in a very
preppy way but this really has a
Continental feel to it
you don't need a navy blazer gold
buttons and paint smoke
exactly that rift on exactly I'd say if
you've got these five ties in your
arsenal or something similar to it
you're gonna be set for the season and I
think what you're gonna want to do is
take those silks a little bit back to
the closet especially for form right
maybe one day they'll come back and
style but this fall it's all about the
waltz all about the walls all right
thank you Jim thank you